ich nehme das schnitzel die neunzigern
gerade angerufen die wollen ihre
ernährung wieder ist ungesund und
schlecht für die umwelt bei der w s denn
so was heute nur halb
ich hätte gerne das tempo mit den grünen
wohnen wo gibt's das beste tempel auch
in der charta jetzt gerne noch nachwuchs
als ich gerade avocado gehört avocado
die grün gewordene globalisierung der
diesel skandal unter den früchten
ich hab's dir
[Musik]
sollte der ernährung kapitel eins ohne
tierische produkte mache ich nichts
falsch
alle lieben die grüne butter vom baum
lecker nahrhaft geile brot streng
genommen ist die avocado eigentlich
keine frucht sondern eine beere der gfb
findet dann umgang mit kritik sehr
kindisch
hier ging der absatz von avocados in
deutschland steigt und steigt 2017 waren
es 57 millionen kilo pro jahr werden
weltweit tausende hektar wald war
avocado wälder gerodet ein kilo avocado
verbraucht im anbau 1000 liter wasser
also sechs badewannen für zweieinhalb
ocado carlos kommt von ganz weit weg in
mexiko brasilien südafrika
zehntausende kilometer mit schiff und
lkw
das sind echte globetrotter viele
avocados haben schon einen eigenen
instagram account wo sie ihre schönsten
reisebilder posten ganz ehrlich
schnitzel vom regionalen bauernhof ist
umweltfreundlicher kapitel 2 es gibt
leckere fleischalternativen für die kein
tier leiden muss es mag ja alles sein
aber statt wurst so ein vegetarisches
ersatzprodukt das ist doch super dass
die gibt es doch heute schon über all
das stimmt fleischlos ist voll im trend
es gibt auch veganer wurst aus soja oder
beißen aber bei denen die rhetorischen
produkten empfehle ich unbedingt ein
blick auf die zutatenliste die hinweise
mit 60 bis 70 also wer glaubt dass
vegetarische aufschnitt gegen
massentierhaltung hilft der glaubt auch
dass rügen war der brust ausreden könnt
könnt ihr nicht
schwarzwälder kirschtorte nur zum teil
und die kirchen sind importiert kapitel
3 kein fleisch keine probleme
gut dann komm ich jetzt keine wurst mehr
aus fleisch sowieso nicht alles nur noch
bio wenn alle so wären wäre ich dann wie
eigentlich alles gut wäre es nicht wir
können alle menschen gar nicht nur mit
pflanzen ernähren rinder ziegen und
schafe fressen was wir nicht essen aber
die crew brüste und verwandelt gras in
protein und es gibt fünf milliarden
hektar land was wir landwirtschaftlich
nutzen können davon sind 3,4 milliarden
weideland es ist eine totale katastrophe
wenn beide wand für tiere umgewandelt
wird in monokulturen für weizen oder
soja massentierhaltung ist mist aber
ganz ohne tierhaltung geht's auch nicht
die ökologische landwirtschaft zum
beispiel braucht tiere auch als dünger
produzenten weil sie auf mineralischen
dünger verzichtet würden jetzt mit einem
mal alle bio kunden vegan leben wäre das
das ende der ökologischen landwirtschaft
da nehme ich nun maiskolben wo ich hab
dazu ganz hervorragendes himalaya salz
ich nehme ich dann was das ist gesund
und ethisch sauber kapitel 4
die malaria salz was bei uns als ihm
alles fertig wird kommt natürlich nicht
aus dem himalaya sondern aus einem
mittelgebirge in pakistan hat den
quatsch auch ein horn salzen oder noch
viel besser idioten salz und das rosa
zeug ist ganz normales steinsalz wie es
auch bei uns vorkommt nur fünfmal so
teuer
der staat hat klingt wie irgendwann wird
sich hitler morgens ausgestreut ein
stück wurst die wahrheit tut weh wird
ihr euch schlecht gut so wisst ihr wie
ihr euch noch viel schlechter fühlt
indem er die nächste folge verpasst oder
abonniert einfach diesen kanal da
passiert das nicht nein